dans certaines villes canadiennes
l'immobilier rendus hors de prix au
début de la campagne justin trudeau a
donc proposé d'aider les premiers
acheteurs mais avec les critères de son
programme died impossible d'acheter une
maison qui vont jusqu'à 800 mille
dollars comme le propose le chef libéral
[Musique]
voici comment fonctionne l'aide proposée
par justin trudeau la société canadienne
d'hypothèques et de logement schl va
prêter de l'argent aux premiers
acheteurs
l'idée c'est de faire baisser le montant
de l'hypothèque à payer chaque mois
comme à toronto vancouver et victoria
le prix de l'immobilier est très élevé
le prix d'achat admissibles peut
atteindre danse et vela 790000 dollars
mais pour avoir droit à cette aide il ya
deux critères
il faut avoir une mise de fonds de 5 %
et votre revenu familial ne doit pas
dépasser 150 mille dollars
et c'est là qu'il y a un problème avec
un revenu brut de 150 mille dollars
il est financièrement très risqués voire
carrément impossible d'acheter une
première maison qui vaut 790000 dollars
selon la calculatrice qu'on peut
retrouver sur le site du gouvernement
fédéral
si vous tenté d'acheter une maison à 7
190 mille dollars avec un revenu de
150000 et la banque devrait vous refuser
le prêt main si vous n'avez aucune dette
si on vous prête cette somme et bien
vous allez être étranglés financièrement
selon cet outil du gouvernement canadien
avec une mise de fonds de 5 % avec
l'aide proposée par justin trudeau
une famille qui gagne 150 mille dollars
par année et qu'il n'a pas de dette peut
se qualifier pour acheter au lieu une
maison dont la valeur est de 640 milles
dollars même si c'est la limite avant de
tomber dans le surendettement 649
dollars c'est beaucoup d'argent mais
dans les quartiers centraux de toronto
de vancouver victoria
c'est peu par exemple à toronto on
demande 599 mille dollars pour ce garage
et le courtier immobilier estime qu'il
s'agit d'une véritable aubaine
cela dit 640 mille dollars c'est tout de
même le prix médian d'un condo d'une
chambre à coucher
mais dans la grande région d'europe